FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAISING THE
STAKES IN THE STAND OF
OVERBUILDING THE BORDER WALL
DURING DAY 13 OF THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
THE PRESIDENT APPEARING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS BRIEFING ROOM
SURROUNDED BY IMMIGRATION AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TO SAY
HE'S NOT BACKING DOWN.
>> WE NEED PROTECTION IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE IT GOOD.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY WANT
IT.
I HAVE NEVER HAD SO MUCH SUPPORT
AS I HAVE IN THE LAST WEEK.
OVER MY STANCE FOR BORDER
SECURITY, FIRM BORDER CONTROL,
AND FOR FRANKLY THE WALL OR THE
BARRIER.
I'VE NEVER HAD ANYTHING LIKE IT
IN TERMS OF CALLS COMING IN, IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE WRITING IN AND
TWEETING AND DOING WHATEVER THEY
HAVE TO DO.
I'VE NEVER HAD THIS MUCH
SUPPORT.
>> Jesse: THOSE OFFICIALS
SUPPORTING THE RESIDENTS CALL
FOR MORE BORDER SECURITY.
>> ANYWHERE YOU LOOK WHERE WE
HAVE BUILT WALLS, THEY HAVE
WORKED.
THEY HAVE BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
NECESSITY FOR BORDER PATROL
AGENTS IN SECURING THE BORDER.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO ASK YOURSELF
THIS QUESTION.
IF I COME TO YOUR HOME, DO YOU
WANT ME TO KNOCK ON THE FRONT
DOOR OR DO YOU WANT ME TO CLIMB
THROUGH THAT WINDOW?
SPEAK OF THESE CRIMINAL ALIENS
HAVE BEEN RELEASED FROM JAIL,
DEPORTED, WILL COME BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAD A PHYSICAL BARRIER, IF WE
HAD A WALL, WE WILL BE ABLE TO
STOP IT.
>> Jesse: THE STALEMATE OVER
MONEY FOR THE BORDER WALL SET TO
INTENSIFY WITH DEMOCRATS
RETAKING CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
NANCY PELOSI IS PROMISING TO PUT
PRESSURE ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
REPUBLICANS AFTER RECLAIMING THE
GAVEL AND THE SPEAKERSHIP JUST
HOURS AGO.
PELOSI IS ALSO INSISTING SHE'S
NOT BUDGING ON COUGHING UP MONEY
FOR THE WALL.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO COME UP
AND GIVE HIM SOME OF THIS MONEY
FOR THE WALL BECAUSE APPARENTLY
THAT IS THE STICKING POINT?
>> NO, NOTHING FOR THE WALL.
THERE IS NO AMOUNT OF PERSUASION
HE CAN DO TO SAY TO US WE WANT
YOU TO DO SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
EFFECTIVE, THAT COST BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
>> Jesse: THIS COMES AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP INVITES
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS BACK TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TOMORROW FOR
MORE SHUTDOWN TALKS AFTER A
CONTENTIOUS BRIEFING ON BORDER
SECURITY YESTERDAY.
DAN, ON A DAY WHEN ALL OF THE
ATTENTION WAS ON NANCY PELOSI,
SPEAKER PELOSI, A BIG CEREMONY
AND THE NIGHTLY NEWSCASTS WERE
GOING TO LEAD WITH IT, THE
PRESIDENT COMES IN AND HOLDS
THIS BIG PRESS BRIEFING
SURROUNDED BY I.C.E. AGENTS AND
BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND KIND OF
STOLE HER THUNDER A LITTLE BIT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS PRETTY
EFFECTIVE.
>> Dan: I THINK THE G.O.P. HAS
GENERALLY HAD A PROBLEM THAT
WITH THE MESSAGE BUT WITH
MESSAGING.
THE GENERAL IDEA OF LOW TAXES,
BORDER SECURITY, HEALTH CARE,
FREEDOM AND CHOICE RESONATES
WITH THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS.
THE PROBLEM IS OUR MESSAGING IS
TERRIBLE.
WE NEVER MANAGED TO FIT THINGS
ON A WHEATIES BOX.
WE GO TO A METHADONE CLINIC AND
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 401(K)s.
WE HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO STATE
AS EASILY AS TRUMP.
THIS IS ABOUT BORDER SECURITY.
THAT THIS METHOD RIGHT NOW.
IT'S CLEAR.
HE IS A MASTER AT TAKING OVER
THE MICROPHONE AND HE JUST DID
IT AGAIN IN THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE.
IT WAS BRILLIANT.
BE SNAPPY, GET OFF THE STAGE.
>> Jesse: TONIGHT'S RESPONSE
TO SPEAKER PELOSI WHO HAS BEEN
SAYING FOR ALMOST A YEAR THAT
WALLS DON'T WORK ANY OF PEOPLE
ON THE BORDER, EXPERTS WHO HAVE
DONE THIS SEVERAL LIFE SAYING
EVERYWHERE WE HAVE PUT A
BARRIER, THEY HAVE STUFFED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> Marie: YOU HAVE OTHER
EXPERTS WHO SAY WE DON'T NEED
THE KIND OF WHILE DONALD TRUMP
IS TALKING ABOUT.
WE NEED SOMETHING IN THE MIDDLE.
THERE'S A WHOLE LIST.
WILL HURD, CONGRESSMAN FROM
TEXAS.
>> Jesse: CIA GUY?
>> Marie: HE'S A REPUBLICAN
MEMBER OF CONGRESS FROM TEXAS
WHO SAID THE MOST COSTLY, LEAST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO BORDER
SECURITY.
>> Jesse: I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
AT ALL.
>> Marie: OKAY, WELL, IT'S
TRUE.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T HOLD UP
PRESS CONFERENCE.
HE DIDN'T TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
SMART.
HE TAKES QUESTIONS AND THEN
STEPPED ON THE MESSAGE.
>> Marie: THAT'S TRUE.
FIRST, YOU HAVE YOU HAVE THE
FIRST REPUBLICAN SENATOR TODAY,
CORY GARDNER FROM COLORADO, COME
ON SAY THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
REOPEN WITH NO WALL FUNDING.
THERE ARE SENATORS ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE HERE WHO MAY DECIDE
THAT THEY WILL VOTE FOR
SOMETHING THE HOUSE PASSES WITH
NO WALL FUNDING.
THIS IS A NUMBERS GAME FOR THE
PRESIDENT AT THIS POINT.
THE OTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE IS
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN CABLE
PUNDITRY, INCLUDING MYSELF, HAVE
STARTED TALKING ABOUT THIS DACA
FOR AWOL FUNDING SWAP.
MY QUESTION IS, IS THAT EVEN
BEING TALKED ABOUT INSIDE THE
NEGOTIATING ROOM?
YOU DON'T HEAR ABOUT IT FROM
TRUMP OR THE WHITE HOUSE.
PELOSI.
THEY ARE IN THEIR CORNERS AND WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT A POSSIBLE
COMPROMISE, BUT ARE THEY?
>> Jesse: WHAT'S HAPPENING
INSIDE NEGOTIATING ROOM THE
OTHER DAY, KIRSTJEN NIELSEN,
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY STARTED TALKING ABOUT
FACTS AND FIGURES THEN CHUCK AND
NANCY CUT HER OFF.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS REALLY MEAN.
>> Kennedy: ACCORDING TO ONE
WHITE HOUSE SOURCE, CHUCK SAID
YOU SHOULD INTERRUPT HER.
SHE WAS PRESENTING DATA.
SHE WAS PRESENTING HER CASE.
SPEAKER PELOSI SAYS THE
PRESIDENT IS ALLERGIC TO DATA
AND FACTS.
CLEARLY THIS IS AN ALLERGY OR AN
AFFLICTION THAT IS SPREADING TO
BOTH PARTIES.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE AT AN IMPASSE.
I DON'T HEAR NANCY PELOSI
TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE HOUSE CAN
DO IN TERMS OF IMMIGRATION.
EVERYONE IS HUNG UP ON THE WALL.
THEY ARE HUNG UP ON THE
FOUR-LETTER WORD AND THEY CAN'T
GET PAST IT.
MEANWHILE THEY HAVE A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T COLLECTING
PAYCHECKS, OTHERS WHO AREN'T
GOING TO WORK ON THOSE WHO ARE
CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE TRYING TO
WORK IN THIS COUNTRY.
BY SOME, THEY ARE BEING
DEMONIZED.
MY QUESTION IS WHAT IF THE WALL
DOESN'T WORK?
THE GREATEST CORRELATION BETWEEN
IMMIGRATION IN THIS COUNTRY AND
WHEN IT PROLIFERATES IS WHEN THE
ECONOMY IS DOING REALLY WELL.
RIGHT NOW THE ECONOMY IS DOING
REALLY WELL.
YOU ALSO HAVE A LOT OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> Dan: YOU GENERALLY BELIEVE
IN FACTS AND DATA, RIGHT?
>> Kennedy: I LOVE IT SO MUCH.
>> Dan: A CORRELATION BETWEEN
CONSTRUCTION AND WALLS IN THE
DECREASING AND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION TRAFFICKING AND DRUG
TRAFFICKING.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT JUST
WENT TO INSTAGRAM AND I THINK
RELEASED A MEME.
THE WALL IS COMING.
THAT IS FROM "GAME OF THRONES."
LET'S GO TO GREG FOR THE BIG
PICTURE.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE BIG
IT'S A BIG PICTURE.
YOU KNOW, I LOOKED AT IT -- AS
PART OF THE MEDIA, WE ARE LIVING
IN DONALD TRUMP'S RESTAURANT.
AROUND 4:30, HE SAYS THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH TRUMP ON YOUR PIZZA.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TRUMP IN YOUR
SOUP SO HE COMES OUT AND PUTS
MORE TRUMP ON YOUR PLATE, WHICH
IS WHAT HE DID, IT HELPS
GALVANIZE THE MEDIA AND EVERYONE
REACTS, RESPONDS.
THE REAL THREAT TO SECURITY IS A
RHETORICAL DEVICE: CONFLATION.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE FOUR
AREAS OF SECURITY, BORDER,
TERROR, CRIME, AND LET'S SAY
HOME PROTECTION -- GUNS.
THOSE ARE THE FOUR AREAS.
IN EACH CASE, THERE IS THE
DEVICE THAT'S USED TO PREVENT
ANY KIND OF IMPROVEMENTS IN THAT
AREA, ITS CONFLATION.
IMMIGRATION, CONFLATE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WITH LEGAL
IMMIGRATION, YOU CAN'T GET A
WALL.
WITH TERROR, IF YOU CONFLATE
RELIGION WITH EXTREMISM, YOU GET
ISLAMAPHOBIA.
THAT PREVENTS ANY MOVEMENT IN
THE ANTI-TERROR WORLD.
IF YOU LOOK AT POLICING, YOU
CONFLATE LAW AND ORDER WITH
RACISM, RIGHT?
POLICE BRUTALITY, POLICE
SHOOTINGS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, YOU CONFLATE
GUN CRIME WITH GUN OWNERSHIP.
THIS IS A TACTIC USED BY THE
LEFT THAT'S EFFECTIVE IN EVERY
AREA OF SECURITY.
IT'S PROBABLY MOST GLARING HERE
BECAUSE WE SEE THAT THEY BOTH
AGREE ON THE SAME THING.
THEY BOTH WANT BORDER
PROTECTION, BUT ONE WON'T BUDGE
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONFLATING IT
WITH BIGOTRY.
IT'S LIKE YOU WANT A WALL?
YOU DON'T LIKE BROWN PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
YOU DON'T LIKE THE PEOPLE.
NO, ACTUALLY IF YOU ASK
HISPANICS HERE, THEY WOULD AGREE
THAT THEY BELIEVE INSECURITY
TOO.
THAT CONFLATION IS WHAT IS
DESTROYING EVERY DEBATE.
>> Jesse: YOU SAY THAT THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE REPUBLICANS
AGREE THEY BOTH WANT BORDER
SECURITY.
I'M NOT SO SURE THE DEMOCRATS
WANT 100% --
>> Greg: WE HAVE PROOF.
WE HAVE THEM SAYING IT.
>> Jesse: JUST BECAUSE THEY
SAY IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S TRUE.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S MY QUESTION
AND I WANT SOMEONE TO POSE THAT
TO CHUCK SCHUMER.
WHY WAS IT OKAY IN 2006 BUT NOT
NOW?
$46 BILLION FOR THE KIND OF
BORDER SECURITY THAT EVERYONE IS
TALKING ABOUT 13 YEARS AGO NOW
BUT YOU ARE NOT OKAY.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
>> Jesse: IF YOU ARE A
REPORTER ON CAPITOL HILL, TAKE
THAT QUESTION FROM KENNEDY AND
ASK CRYING CHUCK SCHUMER.
MAYBE WE CAN GET AN ANSWER AND